>> I'M JOINED
LIVE NOW BY THE MEMPHIS POLICE
CHIEF, CJ DAVIS THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
I'M GOING TO WEAR MY GLASSES
BECAUSE I HAVE SPECIFIC THINGS I
WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT.
THESE FIVE OFFICERS HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH SECOND DEGREE
MURDER IN THE DEATH OF TYRE
NICHOLS.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THESE
VERY SERIOUS CHARGES?
>> WELL, I EXPECTED SERIOUS
CHARGES.
I REALLY DID.
ACTUALLY, THE CHARGES THAT WERE
PLACED -- AT LEAST THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CHARGES WERE
PROBABLY THE MOST SEVERE I'VE
SEEN IN MY CAREER BUT THEY WERE
ABSOLUTELY APPROPRIATE.
I KNEW THAT THE NEXT STEP WOULD
BE IN THE HANDS OF THE DA'S
OFFICE SO I'M NOT SURPRISED.
>> THESE ARE EXTRAORDINARY
MEASURES I MUST SAY IN ALL THE
TIMES I'VE COVERED THESE
INCIDENTS TO FIRE THE OFFICERS
AND CHARGE THEM SO QUICKLY.
DOES THAT SPEAK TO WHAT WE'LL
SEE ON THE VIDEOTAPE WHEN IT'S
RELEASED AFTER 7:00 P.M. EA
EASTERN.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS WE
HAVE TALKED ABOUT POLICE
LEGITIMACY AND POLICE REFORM.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT, IN
INSTANCES LIKE THIS, WHEN THEY
ARE SERIOUS, WHEN THEY DO ARISE
TO THAT LEVEL, WHERE A PERSON'S
CONST
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS, THEIR
CIVIL RIGHTS HAVE BEEN VIOLATED
THAT WE ACT AND ACT SWIFTLY.
>> WHEN DID YOU FIRST LEARN
ABOUT THE INCIDENT, CHIEF?
>> IT WAS PROBABLY 4:00 IN THE
MORNING, THE PREVIOUS DAY, 8:00
AT NIGHT, 9:00, THE INCIDENT
OCCURRED.
ABOUT 4:00 IN THE MORNING I
LEARNED OF THE INCIDENT.
AND IT WAS JUST A STRANGE
SUMMARY OF WHAT OCCURRED ON THE
TRAFFIC STOP.
I DECIDED TO GO IN THE OFFICE
AND MEET WITH THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT HAD INFORMATION THAT I
COULD TAKE A LOOK AT IT, EVEN
THOUGH AT THAT TIME, TYRE WAS IN
THE HOSPITAL, BUT STILL BECAUSE
HE HAD INJURIES THAT JUST -- I
JUST DIDN'T UNDERSTAND.
IT WAS INCOMPREHENSIBLE TO ME.
WE CAME IN THE OFFICE AND
DECIDED TO TAKE A LOOK THAT
SUNDAY MORNING AND IT WAS
ALARMING.
>> THAT'S WHEN YOU -- SUNDAY
MORNING IS WHEN YOU FIRST SAW
THE VIDEO?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WHEN YOU SAW IT, WHAT WAS
YOUR REACTION?
>> I WAS -- I WAS OUTRAGED.
I WAS -- IT WAS INCOMPREHENSIBLE
TO ME.
IT WAS UNCONSCIONABLE.
I FELT THAT I NEEDED TO DO
SOMETHING AND DO SOMETHING
QUICKLY.
I DON'T THINK I WITNESSED
ANYTHING OF THAT NATURE MY
ENTIRE CAREER.
>> REALLY?
>> REALLY.
>> THAT BAD?
>> IT WAS THAT BAD.
>> WHAT ARE WE GOING TO SEE
THEN?
>> YOU'RE GOING TO SEE ACTS THAT
DEFY HUMANITY.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A DISREGARD
FOR LIFE.
DUTY OF CARE THAT WE'RE ALL
SWORN TO.
AND A LEVEL OF PHYSICAL
INTERACTION THAT IS ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT IS REQUIRED IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND I'M SURE THAT, YOU KNOW, AS
I SAID BEFORE, THAT INDIVIDUALS
WATCHING WILL FEEL WHAT THE
FAMILY FELT.
AND IF YOU DON'T, THEN YOU'RE
NOT A HUMAN BEING.
AND WE ALL ARE HUMAN BEINGS.
AND I THINK THERE WILL BE A
MEASURE OF SADNESS AS WELL.
>> HOW LONG DO THESE INCIDENTS
GO ON?
WE HEARD FROM THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY YESTERDAY AND FROM THE
HEAD OF THE TBI THAT THERE WERE
TWO SEPARATE INCIDENTS, RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> HOW LONG DO THEY GO ON AND
WHEN -- WHAT WAS THE WORST PART
OF IT?
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN SAID THAT
THE OFFICERS BECAME CHARGED
DURING THE SECOND INCIDENT, THAT
THEY GOT MORE RILED UP.
>> WELL, FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
TO ME THEY WERE RILED UP.
I DON'T THINK THEY WERE AS AMPED
UP AS THEY WERE AT THE SECOND
SCENE BUT JUST THE STOP, THE
NATURE OF THE STOP, VERY
AGGRESSIVE, LOUD, YOU KNOW,
COMMUNICATION.
AND IT WAS -- IT JUST ROSE FROM
THERE.
IT ESCALATED FROM THERE.
MR. NICHOLS WAS ABLE TO GET AWAY
FROM THESE OFFICERS AND THEY
FOUND HIM, AGAIN, AT ANOTHER
LOCATION AND AT THAT POINT,
THERE WAS AN AMOUNT OF
AGGRESSION THAT IS
UNEXPLAINABLE.
YOU KNOW, IN ANY INSTANCE WHERE
YOU'RE APPREHENDING SOMEONE --
EVEN IN THE WORST SITUATION
WHERE THERE IS RESISTANCE,
OFFICERS STILL HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO EXERCISE CARE
AND REGARD FOR ANY INDIVIDUAL
THAT'S IN CUSTODY OR THEY'RE
ATTEMPTING TO APPREHEND, AND
THEY'RE TRAINED TO DO THAT.
>> AND TO DE-ESCALATE.
THAT'S THE PIECE, I THINK, THAT
IS IN QUESTION.
BUT I THINK THE ESCALATION WAS
THERE FROM THE OFFICERS BEFORE
TRAINING EVEN NEEDED TO COME IN
AS IT RELATES TO DE-ESCALATE.
THE ESCALATION WAS ALREADY AT A
HIGH LEVEL.
>> YOU'RE SAYING THEY DID
EVERYTHING WRONG?
YOU THINK THIS WAS OUTSIDE OF
THEIR TRAINING, EVERYTHING.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> YOU MENTIONED, YOU SAID THE
NATURE OF THE STOP.
>> YES.
>> CAN WE TALK ABOUT THE NATURE
OF THE STOP.
>> YES.
>> WHAT WAS THE NATURE?
WHY WAS HE STOPPED?
>> I'M GOING TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU ABOUT THE STOP ITSELF.
WHAT WAS SAID WAS THAT THERE WAS
WITNESSING OF WHAT WAS
CONSIDERED RECKLESS DRIVING.
WE'VE LOOKED AT CAMERAS, WE'VE
LOOKED AT BODY-WORN CAMERAS.
AND EVEN IF SOMETHING OCCURRED
PRIOR TO THE STOP, WE'VE BEEN
UNABLE TO SUBSTANTIATE THAT AT
THIS TIME.
>> YOU HAVE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
SUBSTANTIATE --
>> THE RECKLESS DRIVING.
>> AT ALL?
>> NO.
WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
SUBSTANTIATE THE RECKLESS
DRIVING.
>> THAT WAS WHY HE WAS
SUPPOSEDLY STOPPED.
SUPPOSEDLY STOPPED IN THE VERY
BEGINNING.
THAT WAS A CONCERN.
SO IN AN INVESTIGATION WE BEGIN
TO LOOK AT WHAT WAS THE PROBABLE
CAUSE FOR THE STOP, WHERE WERE
THE CAMERAS?
WAS THERE SOME EVIDENCE ON THE
BODY CAMERA, ALONG THOSE CAMERAS
ON THOSE THOROUGHFARES?
AND WE'VE TAKEN AN EXTENSIVE
LOOK TO DETERMINE WHAT THAT
PROBABLE CAUSE WAS AND HE HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO SUBSTANTIATE
THAT.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT SOMETHING
DIDN'T HAPPEN --
>> BUT THE CAMERAS --
>> -- THERE'S NO PROOF.
>> SO BEFORE THE INCIDENT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT OTHER SURVEILLANCE
CAMERAS AROUND THE CITY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THOROUGHFARES, AND EVEN BUSINESS
CAMERAS.
ANY FOOTAGE WE COULD PICK UP TO
SEE WHAT OCCURRED PRIOR TO THE
STOP?
THE INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW OF -- BASED ON WHAT WE
COULD OBSERVE IS THE STOP ITSELF
AND THE FIRST OFFICER EXITING
HIS VEHICLE, YOU'LL SEE THAT ON
THE BODY WORN CAMERA.
AT THAT TIME, THE OFFICERS WERE
ALREADY AGGRESSIVE AND AMPED UP.
>> AND AMPED UP.
>> UM-HUM.
>> SO YOU HAVEN'T FOUND ANYTHING
TO SUBSTANTIATE THE RECKLESS
DRIVING.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AND THIS WAS JUST FEET FROM
HIS HOME.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
THREE BLOCKS AWAY.
>> HE WAS APPREHENDED BY THE
SCORPION LEADERSHIP, LAUNCHED
UNDER YOUR LEADERSHIP IN 2021.
>> YES.
>> WERE THEY LOOKING FOR SOME
OTHER CRIME OTHER THAN RECKLESS
DRIVING FROM TYRE NICHOLS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
WELL, THE SCORPION UNITS, STREET
CRIME OPERATIONS TO REPORT PIECE
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
IT WAS BASED ON THE FACT THAT WE
HAD AN OUTCRY BECAUSE OF THREE
YEARS OF VIOLENCE IN THE CITY.
NUMBERS OF VIOLENT CRIMES,
ROBBERIES, HOMICIDES, AGGRAVATED
ASSAULTS, AND THIS IS ONE OF
THREE TEAMS, WHOSE PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO REDUCE GUN
VIOLENCE, TO BE VISIBLE IN
COMMUNITIES, AND TO ALSO IMPACT
THE RISE IN THE CRIME.
BASICALLY OUT OF AN OUTCRY FROM
THE COMMUNITY.
WE HAD RECORD NUMBERS IN 2021,
346 HOMICIDES.
SO THIS UNIT WAS PUT TOGETHER
AND THEY HAD GREAT SUCCESS,
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, LAST YEAR.
IT WAS THE FIRST YEAR IN A LONG
TIME --
>> IS THIS AN INDICATION OF A
FAILURE IN THAT UNIT?
>> THIS IS AN INDICATION THAT
THERE IS A GAP SOMEWHERE IN THAT
UNIT.
MY OBSERVATION IS THAT, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE SEVERAL
CONTRIBUTING FACTORS.
WE TRAIN AND WE RE-TRAIN THESE
OFFICERS JUST LIKE SPECIALIZED
UNITS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THESE OFFICERS IN WORKING IN
SPECIALIZED UNITS, YOU ALWAYS
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE SUPER
VISION IS THERE AND PRESENT.
>> DO YOU FEAR THEY HAVE DONE
ANYTHING LIKE THIS IN THE PAST?
DO YOU HAVE ANY EVIDENCE OF
THAT?
>> WE DON'T HAVE EVIDENCE OF IT
AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
HOWEVER WE'RE TAKING A DEEPER
DIVE INTO PREVIOUS ARRESTS,
PREVIOUS VIDEO CAMERA FOOTAGE.
WE ALSO REACHED OUT TO THE IACP,
WHO WILL WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WE'VE ASKED THE IACP AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO COME IN
AND LOOK AT OUR SPECIALIZED
UNITS.
WE DON'T WANT ANY GAPS IN ANY OF
OUR UNITS.
>> I'VE HEARD ABOUT YOU FROM
EVERY SINGLE PERSON THAT I SPOKE
TO THAT THE BUCK STOPS WITH YOU.
>> YEAH.
>> DO YOU FEEL YOU HAVE ANY
RESPONSIBILITY IN THE FAILURE OF
THE UNIT?
>> I CAN'T REMOVE MYSELF FROM
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND, OF COURSE, WE CAN'T ALWAYS
BE WITH OUR OFFICERS BUT IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US TO ACT AND
HAVE CHECKS AND BALANCES IN
PLACE.
BUT WE HAVE TO RELY ON THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ALSO IN
SUPERVISORY POSITIONS AND
COMMANDERS' POSITIONS BUT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY IS THROUGHOUT THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT UP TO THE
CHIEF.